so we're building a cannon right suzuko
it's a sort of trap with Tracy brands
help and hrs help
they've create this device called the
speedforce bazooka little tiny oval we
need by my calculation ordering point
eight six tera joules of energy that's
more energy than in the Sun the only way
to stop savat are is with this bazooka
but if you can't power it to kind of
help us so there is a power source and
the power source is in Argos of all
places that's great you can't have it
very yes lyla won't let us have the
Dominator stack then we are going to
break into Argos and we're going to
steal it no you won't yes what is that
they installed power dampeners
throughout this Argos facility and so
Barry can use his powers so you're
saying this is the most fortified
structure in the history of fortified
structures they can't use their
superpowers and we have less than 14
hours to steal the thing and none of us
are naturally no we're not
so Barry realizes if I can't use my
powers then I need a master thief and
that master thief is Leonard snart aka
Captain Cold
hello flash I need your help so Mary
traveled back to the Waverider in
Legends to get that version of Captain
Cold and to bring him back to the
present day tough huh awkward and there
is a very large offender of the power
source and that is none other than King
shark
hey everybody happy for last day so we
got so much to unpack here the key to
defeating sabotage is this giant weapon
so there is going to be a new flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so we're finally at the point in
the show where they're using the Speed
Force in novel ways they're using it to
power weapons argus has learned how to
block various powers I don't think we'll
ever quite get to the point we got to
during the new 52 flash run where the
Darwin Alliance character who's kind of
a Harrison wells type tries to use the
flash of Speed Force energy for sinister
purposes or at least take credit for
something that he doesn't deserve so you
can see that there are elements of that
in the show already but he ends up
trying to use the Flash's excess speed
forces this source of renewable energy
if you like claiming you came up with
cold fusion but really you're just
stealing power from someone to get their
power from dark matter in another
dimension it did lead to all kinds of
crazy problems in the creation of the
Daniell West reverse flash who actually
just came back and rebirth a little
while ago but the fun thing about this
episode is that even though it seems
like a casual heist and they kind of
explain some of the logic so we know
which version of Captain Cold this is
they're getting the dominator power
source to power the speed bazooka so
that they can defeat saboteur and trap
him in the Speed Force prison but on the
past is that they are going to cause so
much havoc that they'll be able to
capitalize on in season 4 if they want
to so just like season 1 where Harrison
wells tries to power up the reactor
again so that he can go back home Barry
can go back and save his mother creates
this giant wormhole in this guy that
almost sucks the city up into it
there'll be all kinds of crazy
consequences to their actions in the
next two episodes so hopefully they
don't leave them flying in the wind I'm
hoping that they don't completely fix
captain cold so that's the back door to
him coming back during season 4 so this
version of Captain colds just to clarify
is very going back in time to the
timeline during season 1 of legends of
tomorrow
so the Captain Cold that was flying
around last year on legends of tomorrow
still alive that's who we're talking to
here so he hasn't sacrificed himself he
hasn't experienced anything from season
2 of legends of tomorrow so he'll have
no memory of the spear of destiny or any
of that adventure but the other hat tip
here is that Lyla
already has anti speedster technology in
place guarding this alien power source
that's a bit of a twist like you always
wonder why can't the flash do this on
his own he's one of the most powerful
people on the earth the best way to
counteract that and keep him from
getting to opie is to have scientists
like Tracy brand come up with technology
other scientists that are really smart
find ways of dampening his power so you
take his powers away he's just another
really smart scientist never forget that
Barry Allen is a scientist even though
they don't always have him doing CSI
stuff every single episode but we talked
about it before the legends of tomorrow
Waverider has anti speedster guns they
used it on the reverse-flash so it's
really funny seeing Barry plan a heist
with one of the Rogues to break into
Argus and steal a power source even
though it's for a good reason they have
to solve the problem of sabotage but
it's not like Lila is just going to roll
over and take that what do you think
she's going to do next season to stop
him from doing stuff like that if Amanda
Waller was still around she would
definitely beef up her anti speedster
Arsenal and she would reform a new
version of the Suicide Squad
so yes King shark was a member of the
Suicide Squad they technically haven't
reformed it officially yet even though
there's a lot of Suicide Squad
characters that are going to be in the
arrow finale so it's still a little
early to start talking about what's
going to be happening in season four so
just start looking for things in the
next two episodes
that'll come back to haunt them in a big
way next season so we have a scientist
who's learning all about the Speed Force
what if someone were to misuse that
knowledge I think there's a certain
amount of value in keeping it a little
bit mysterious you start over explaining
how the force works in Star Wars and it
starts to make it feel less special
so no midi-chlorians on the flash but
there's all kinds of fun stuff that you
can pull from it in terms of story like
you start to learn to use it other
people who are not speedsters can also
learn how to use it for all kinds of
mischief big question though let me know
in the comments do you want them to
fridge Savitt are at the end of the
season and when I say fridge I mean like
completely kill the character in a way
that will not enable him to come back so
I Barry learns the lesson don't create
time remnants don't try to change the
past so he doesn't lead to the creation
of another saboteur but also getting rid
of the one that exists right now come
lately the other option would be to trap
him in the speedforce prison and just
leave him there in case you ever want to
use him again during a big villain
team-up like you bring the black flash
back because he's really important
concept for speedsters he's the specter
of death for speedsters you're never
going to get rid of the black flash you
just have different versions of the
black flash but a character likes avatar
who has like this crazy speed he has
this fearsome suit that makes him wave
faster than the flash that's an
important thing too he's faster when
he's in this suit you can always bring
him back in a future season for a single
episode or for some big speedster
villain team-up but a lot of times the
people that they bring back just depend
on how much the writers and the
producers like the wait works out like
they really like the Eddie character so
even though they kill him off they still
bring him back because fans like him and
it's just a really fun twist for him to
show up as a Speed Force wormhole alien
so let me know into the season they fix
the problem with avatar do you ever want
to see him come back now they did
already confirm the season 4 villain
will not be a speedster villain now
there will be villain speedsters it's
just that the biggest villain will not
be a speedster villain they're implying
that it's going to be devote this
thinker we can talk more about that
after the finale I'll remind everyone
about the giveaway later tonight in the
giveaway will continue during the off
season I'll still be doing flash ring
giveaway just start thinking about the
flash DC TV stuff you guys want to talk
about during the off season I've also
got an injustice to review that I'll try
and post before the flash starts tonight
while you wait for that you can click
here for new Justice League and you can
click here for all my flash videos thank
you so much for watching
what's that 5 I'll see you guys tonight